europe where this week could see
britain's hottest day ever recorded with
high temperatures potentially reaching
at least 103 degrees fahrenheit that's
not just above normal that is 30 degrees
above normal the same heat wave is
already being blamed for extreme
temperatures and widespread wildfires
across other parts of europe you're
looking at the pictures and scientists
say this is all part of climate change
caused by human activity roxanna siberia
is tracking europe's hot weather and the
damage it's causing
wildfires raging across southwest france
have scorched around 35 thousand acres
and forced more than 16 thousand people
to flee
in spain the scene seemed similarly
apocalyptic
neighboring portugal remains on high
alert after fires were found by drought
that's hit at least 96 percent of the
country and a heat wave reaching a
record of nearly 117 degrees here and in
spain authorities say more than 1 000
people have died from the recent heat
and now britain is bracing for its
record high of at least 103 degrees on
tuesday so hot the uk's national weather
service has issued its first ever red
warning for extreme heat meaning there's
a risk to life
scientists say heat waves have become
more frequent and more intense and last
longer climate change has everything to
do with extreme weather that we're
seeing at the moment and it's
human-induced climate change it's not a
natural variation christie mccabe is a
meteorologist at the uk's royal
meteorological society is weather like
this going to become the norm
unfortunately yes that's exactly where
we are heading at the moment if we don't
do something now and take drastic action
we'll continue to see these things
happening
here in london people are trying to cool
off in any way they can this country is
more used to the clouds and rain than to
this kind of heat in fact most homes
don't even have air conditioning either
do most schools some have canceled
classes and people are being told to
avoid the trains because the heat could
buckle the tracks